[Musique]
diane et émile viennent de vendre leur
maison ils ont loué bel appartement
flambant neuf
au bout d'un an ils reçoivent un avis
d'augmentation pour adultes de 35 $ par
mois
ces trois pour cent de plus que cette
année le trouve cette augmentation
exagérée pour un logement construit il y
à peine un an
le propriétaire leur dit qu'il est dans
son droit pau sur des comptes jan elle
s'adresse à la régie du logement pour
contester l'augmentation mauvaises
surprises
elle apprend qu'elle n'a aucun recours
parce qu'elle habite un logement
construit depuis moins de cinq ans et
dans ce cas il est indiqué dans le bail
locataires et propriétaires ne peuvent
demander à la régie de fixer le loyer si
diane et emilie refuse de payer 35 $ de
plus par mois
ils doivent quitter le logement c'est
écrit noir sur blanc par contre le
propriétaire doit avoir coché la case
avant la signature du bail
sinon une clause ne s'applique pas le
fin mot de l'histoire
tous affectionner les nouvelles
constructions mais fier ni les
augmentations